as we've been hearing more and more
company executives are joining the
argument now about the referendum today
more than a hundred business leaders
added their names to a declaration in
favor of independence one of those was
frank mckergan a former
global head of equities at rbs the royal
bank of scotland thank you for joining
us
mr mckergan
why have you decided to support
independence when so many other
business leaders have decided that
independence would be bad for the
scottish economy well i think it's wrong
to suggest that there's a whole bunch of
business people on the north side and
only one or two on the yes side through
the campaign i've met literally hundreds
of business people who are convinced by
the yes argument and again and can see
beyond the short-term issues that the no
campaign are throwing out and are much
more excited by the longer term business
opportunities for scots in scotland
what about standard today uh suggesting
that if independence comes they are
going to shift out of scotland and into
england i think what they're talking
about is contingency plans so what
they're saying is that um they are
putting plans together in case a whole
bunch of negative scenarios come about
but i don't see those scenarios coming
about i think there will be a currency
union and there will be a single market
for financial products in the united
kingdom because it's in the best
interest of all parts of what is
currently the united kingdom for that to
be so but i can understand company
executives looking at all sorts of
scenarios that i think are frankly
unlikely and coming up with contingency
plans for that this is nothing new from
standard life they've said this before
it's continuously planning for a
scenario that i don't see coming about
but what you're doing is pinning your
hopes on saying i know better than the
governor of the bank of england i know
better than the chance of the exchequer
i know better
than ed balls all of whom have made it
very clear
that they do not see a currency union
coming about after independence for the
obvious reason that the remaining
members of the united kingdom want to
control their currency and if they had a
currency union with an independent
nation they wouldn't have that control i
think to be fair to the westminster
politicians it seems like they've only
started thinking about these issues in
the last couple of weeks that the
campaign has got incredibly well to be
fair to the governor of the bank of
england he made that speech right back
at the beginning of the year but i don't
expect in the result in the result of a
yes vote i don't expect the rest of the
uk to do scotland any favors but i do
expect them to behave with rational
self-interest i think in the aftermath
of a yes vote if everyone sits down and
looks at the situation say what's in the
best interests of both parties to me
it's absolutely blindingly clear that
that is a currency union with the single
market for financial services
but it also brightly clear isn't it that
were you to be right were there to be a
currency union the sort of financial
disciplines which are being required
currently in all of the uk and would
still be required in the rest of the uk
would mean that alex salmon couldn't
possibly deliver on the economic
promises he's making on welfare and
other things well not surprisingly i
strongly disagree with that i think um
the the plans have been put forward in
the s campaign are eminently achievable
but if what you're saying is that
smoking we're not with the currency
union when you've signed away that
control
i think a currency is the best interest
of both parties and i think scotland can
prosper within that and the same as many
countries have prospered within currency
unions and for people like paul krugman
to come up with scarce stories about um
what happened in the eurozone i think is
is just totally unrealistic that is not
what would happen in a currency union
between scotland and the rest of the uk
why
because one one of the reasons why you
had problems in the eurozone would not
be replicated in a currency union in the
uk you had
countries in the eurozone at completely
different levels of productivity
completely different stages of economic
development scotland and the rest of the
uk have almost identical levels of
productivity and in very similar
economic stages of development as two
very imminent economies who are part of
the uh the commission uh professors
merlies and professor stiglitz pointed
out that's an eminently stable and
suitable um monetary environment for
scotland to prosper within
but why if the scots people decide to
vote for independence
should the rest of the uk
continue to underwrite the scottish
economy it doesn't seem to make sense if
you want to go your own way go your own
way but don't expect other people to
pick up the bill but i don't see it as
the rest of the uk picking up the bill
for scotland i think scotland wants to
sustain underwriting the scottish
economy
being the lender of last resort would be
doing exactly that wouldn't it well for
an independent scotland the financial
sector would be smaller as a percentage
of gdp than it is in the uk currently so
i don't see that being a problem
yes but it would still be the situation
that uh given important companies like
rbs which he used to work for based in
scotland that if there was a currency
union that would mean that voters in
england voters in wales voters in
northern ireland would be underwriting
the economic performance of those banks
and i'm just saying if you want to go
your own way why would you expect voters
in those countries to do that first of
all the hard work that's been done in
every bank in the world in the last five
or six years has been to make banks
safer capital ratios are multiples of
what they were before the crisis number
one second point is when governments are
involved in bailing out financial
institutions it's a multilateral effort
the british government got involved in
bailing out the irish banks the federal
reserve reserve provided hundreds of
billions of dollars in liquidity
to uk banks like rbs and barclays
because that's where the economic assets
were deployed so bailouts in the future
should they come about and i hope they
don't and we should regulate to make
sure that that's that's increasingly
unlikely are done on a multilateral
basis based upon where the economic
assets are deployed
mr mckagan thank you very much indeed
for joining us